[Music]
saving the bees and effort underway to
help these pollinators Mary Jane
ballessa explains what assembly Bill 221
would do and the role bees play in
southern Nevada
apples peaches and pears it's just one
of the many fruits at Gilcrease Orchard
that fueled the farm and provide for our
community Mark Rubin the director of
Gilcrease Orchard says they can't do it
without a Little Help from these so we
just make a high for them we give them
some sugar water so that they can they
can start developing their own comb and
and their their own honey bees are an
important part of Gilcrease Orchard they
help carry pollen in between blossoms
which can help fertilize the fruit trees
in February we have flowering
um
our trees start to flower especially the
peaches they'll start first and then the
the plums and the apricots they all
flower and and you'll see the bee
activity on those on warm days that's
why Patrick Donnelly the Great Basin
director at the center for biological
diversity says protecting bees is
crucial Donnelly has been following
assembly Bill 221 which would protect
bees and butterflies under the wildlife
classification in Nevada currently these
pollinators aren't managed by the Nevada
Department of Wildlife or any state
agency he says if the bill is passed and
DOW can determine what needs to be done
to protect bees whether it's the
vegetation bees get pollen and nectar
from or more there's a lot we don't know
about which bees and butterflies live in
Nevada and uh and what their
conservation status is I think the other
big one is habitat restoration you know
taking various measures to promote
better habitat for pollinators Donnelly
says insect populations are vulnerable
and this bill would help preserve our
environment and food supply without a
desert ecosystem this is just Nevada is
just a pile of dust and uh and we
actually know it's an amazing biodiverse
place and that insects are the
Cornerstone of those ecosystems the
committee deadline for assembly Bill 221
is a few weeks away now if the house
committee on natural resources passes it
the bill would head to the assembly
floor